man in a box by Kevin Eugene Davis is
this your first leading role no no I've
had I've had other leading leading roles
in feature films do you remember how you
were offered the role yeah actually my
friend Warren Bob who plays sunny in the
film as a friend of mine and we worked
together on a bunch of projects couple
plays a couple other films that we've
done and I he called me he was like you
know they needle bitterly dropped out or
they need a lead for this film when I
was like out really are they I mean are
they auditioning like whether they need
somebody now I'm like really interesting
would you send me the script and the
director kind of knew of me before Kevin
new new of me and he sent me the script
and I read it and I was like yeah I'd
like to get involved in this is that
cool and um he kind of I think he saw
some stuff I've done or he checked my
stuff out on I me be or something that
offered me the role straight out by
actually net for audition for it which
is interesting I don't know if I'm
allowed to say that so that was our
Kevin great yeah yeah I had a I had a
real before the most recent one and I
think he saw that and was sold that I
could play Ryan so that's how it how it
kind of went down and I went to the
table read and then I was on sat
shootings movie and where did they shoot
wilkes-barre Pennsylvania wow I was
about two and a half hour drive from New
York City and how long were you there ah
we shot I would total of a while it was
like three weekends three was like total
of nine ten days shooting we drive we
leave the city on like friday cheap you
know friday saturday sunday maybe monday
and then drive back to New York that was
for about three or four weekends in a
row and when you're preparing for your
scenes are you kind of by yourself or do
you prefer to be amongst people I like
to rehearse my scene partner to go over
beats different moment
you know in the scene I do like to be on
my own to going to my own intentions and
things that I want to do when she even
seen
you